coven infections may be ticking up
slightly this summer but the numbers
remain low overall compared to where
they were during the height of the
pandemic yet the media seems all too
ready to go back to the way things were
back in 2020. we're seeing headlines
like these the LA Times covid-19 is
heating up all around this summer should
we be wearing masks again CBS News the
best n95 face mask deals available now
the liberal networks are also working
hard to push the masked narrative
a mass can be your best friend keep it
private back in time we've had them in
our pockets in our coats and our
backpacks time to bring them out again
especially as the school season starts
we don't want to see kids missing school
for things that we could have prevented
you should be wearing masks in crowded
areas especially during a search uh but
what about at home when you're walking
on the street so certainly at home it
works if you want to reduce household
transmission question I wouldn't wear a
mask when walking your dog just be
distant of other people it's been a long
time since I've even really even thought
about covet but why are the cases going
up and where well it's a combination of
people letting down their guard just
because you think you're done with kova
doesn't mean that virus is not still
circulating letting our guard down how
well we're not masking as much for
example in public transportation so on
the plane
should we should we well if you're in a
crowded indoor public space you might
want to
nope not him never again all right Dr
Nicole Sapphire unless I'm around
somebody who's immunocompromised in 95.
well that's because you're an
intelligent pragmatic individual anyone
who is immunocompromised or if you work
with people who are immunocompromised
those are the people in appropriate
settings should consider wearing a high
quality mask like an n95 not you know a
single layer cloth or surgical masses
don't actually work as we've seen by
many many studies but to actually say
you know to wear masks again in the
house and just being in public spaces
like we have to move on and the reason
you have an uptick in cases right now is
not because you did something wrong it's
because for the last several years we
see an uptick in cases in the winter and
we also see one in the end of summer
this is just a normal cycle of this
respiratory virus and people just need
to accept that this is it moving forward
and you may see calls for people masking
again because the CDC and others are
still recommending if you test positive
for covid that you have to take some
people are still saying five days off
from work and so people are panicking
about that the bottom line covet is not
what it was three years ago and we have
to move forward with this this doesn't
mean that you have to quarantine it's
just if you're sick stay home if you're
buying immunocompromised person consider
wearing a mask but they certainly should
be wearing a mask when I hear those
people on TV I go
I don't listen to you know what it
reminds me of when you're driving and
you turn around and someone's by
themselves in their car wearing a mask I
mean this is insane and to wear a mask
in your own home so now they're trying
to strip you of a home ownership but
when when you do buy a home you have to
wear a mask I mean the whole thing is
that's that's in the hopes that you pass
out because it's 80 degrees on your
thermostat so it's probably a better
alternative than living in that
environment I was on a plane with a lady
sitting next to me and this mask she
pulled out of her purse it looked like
it was about five years old all gnarly
she puts it on then she's pulling it
down at every turn to talk to people to
get on the phone to drink something
what's the point and it's not an n95
mask it is one of these very thin
surgical numbers which you know it's a
Shamira of Health protection when I
think we have to as you said move past
it and realize covet is very different
today than it was a few years well and
also when you wear a
works if you wear a tight mask and you
don't remove it by moving it down to eat
and drink you really but if there is a
small benefit it's now moot point and by
the way there are consequences to
wearing tight-fitting masks masks for
long periods of time and people have to
benefit or they really have to balance
the risk and benefit and I can tell you
we should just move on okay have some
comments you know PBS one of those clips
about masking in your home was from PBS
these are the same people who brought on
Expert saying that climate anxiety is
healthy so the question where you're
getting this advice from but secondly I
would say for all the questions asked
about Mass what are the questions about
kids I mean I can confirm that it feels
like kids in kindergarten preschool are
sicker than ever before after being
quarantined uh developmental
disabilities the lack of being able to
express emotion because you've seen
adults in Mass throughout covid CDC data
between 2019 and 2021 developmental
disabilities between the ages of three
and Seventeen increased by 17 for all
the media panting about whether to wear
a mask start panting and asking the
damage we've done to our children well
no one was Raising that concern well not
no one we were here a lot raising the
concern about the kids and the
consequences of it but they are still
not sounding the alarm the way that they
should you have two young kids you see
it firsthand I see it firsthand as well
but again they're continuing to push it
under the rug and this is just a matter
of virtue it's our last the school
should never have been closed and
children should never have been masked
oh by the way mass type Mass they cause
styes on your eye and chalazian cysts I
have photos on my phone that I will not
share with you wow
my sis and sinus issues too by the way
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights